hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it's the
finals of the chestable masters
knockouts pregnant versus dingler and
the both of them had uh pushed some
really big stones to get here pregnant
defeated aneesh giri and ding defeated
magnus carlsen to you the finals and now
they will face each other four games of
rapid and then of course if it's uh if
it's still drawn then we're going into
blitz and then of course armageddon uh
so this is the first game of the match
let's dive straight into it there is
quite a lot to enjoy prague with the
white pieces opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 c for e6 and knight to c3
and just when everyone thought we were
going to see another nimzo indian ding
just goes for a nice d5 and we have a
queen's gambit declined on the board uh
prague trades once in the center and
goes bishop to g5 going for the old
position line we have c6 uh e3 and h6
now challenging the bishop this is
always useful we create some breeding
room for our king and we
push the bishop back a little bit so
bishop h4 bishop to e7 and bishop to d3
we have castles and knight g to e2 uh
rook to e8 we have castles and now
knight b37 and prague grabs more space
on the queen side with a4 now knight to
h5 offering a trade of dark square
bishops and prague trades with bishop
captures queen captures and pawn to a5
grabbing even more squares here
on the queen side and there is a game in
the database um fabiano corwano headed
against the alireza philosophy where a6
was played right away uh that game ended
in a draw but here ding just goes knight
to f8 and it is now as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game
with the idea of bringing the bishop
over to g4 so prague plays knights to c1
he takes the g4 square for himself also
the knight is coming to b3 knights to f6
the ding ring maneuvers the knight back
knights to b3 and now rook to b8
preparing to push b6 uh we have queen to
c2 and now pawn to b6 we have captures
captures and knight back to d2 now
we have c5 ding starts pushing his queen
side pawns uh knight to f3 and nodding
says all right um i don't i don't have
to capture i can just advance and then
grab even more space here so here's c4
challenging the bishop we have bishop to
f5 offering a trade of light square
bishops and the ding continues pushing
with b5
knights to e5 this is a beautiful square
for the knight it's not going to be easy
to kick it away from there bishop
captures an f5 queen captures and now we
have pawn to b4 challenging this knight
knights the e2 and now rook to a8
offering a trade of brooks and uh now
you can see that uh it can it can be
very dangerous uh prague with his knight
on e5 has constant pressure on this f7
square so dean will have to keep an eye
on this but he can also play queen to be
seven from b7 the queen also controls
the df7 square and then he can start
pushing maybe c3 right away maybe b3
just to get that pawn a little bit
closer to promotion and then we bust
open with c3 all depends on how uh
prague plays this position so here we
have knight to f4 prague brings another
attacker into the game and knight the e6
now offering a trade of knights uh
prague says all right but trade of these
nights not these nights uh and the ding
goes knight to e4 and here it's better
just a trade for example captures
captures and then you play b3 and this
will be very good for ding however ding
played knights to e4 first and he missed
a very very uh clean tactic uh by prague
but luckily for ding prague also missed
it here after knight to e4 you just have
to play rook capture 78 and after rook
captures you play knight captures on c4
the idea being that after upon captures
you will capture this knight then black
has this counter attack knight captures
on d4 and after e captures on a
d4 we're going to play d captures on c4
and we're going to get this position
where it looks ugly of course black will
always be a little bit better here he
does have pressure here but if you are
able to stop this you also have a pass d
pawn so you should have sufficient
counter play uh but prague played knight
back to g3 uh and now thing goes knight
back to d6 we have queen to f3 the queen
is attacked on f5 and now ding just
plays queen to b7 so it's gonna be very
very difficult to stop these pawns uh
knight back to f5 and now knight to g5
attacking the queen here queen f4 and
now ding trades captures captures and
the knights the e4 so keeping the
keeping the tension
uh here we have h3 uh not a good move
inside for prague he has to just wait
for ding to start pushing those pawns
and the b3
we have king to h2 and now of course c3
the knight from e for regards to c3
square so everything is perfectly fine b
captures we have rook captures on a1
rook captures and now knight captures
and c3 regarding that we b1 square and
now you see that uh once this uh pawn
gets the b2 it's uh it's going to be
insta impossible to stop it so here
prague makes one last attempt at saving
the position he plays rook to a3 and it
seems like
like a move that ding might want to play
because i mean why wouldn't you just
push b2 the problem is after b2 there's
the incredible rook b3 that was prague's
idea now just attacking the queen and
also the b2 pawn and if you capture on
b3 you really don't have a better better
option then we go into queen captures on
f7 king to h8 or h7 and we either get a
perpetual depending on where the king
goes or or or we always get a perpetual
it's just a matter of um
which line the the black king chooses to
to get a perpetual but basically queen
to g6 queen to e8 we're gonna continue
checking and that's a draw uh ding
doesn't fall for this dean just plays
rook to f8 he protects his f7 pawn and
says now my pawn is just unstoppable
so knights to d3 and pawn to b2 yeah we
have knight captures on b2 there is no
other way to play this queen captures on
b2 now ding is up a full knight and rook
to a6
we have queen to b7 attacking the rook
rook to a1 and now we have knight back
to e4 and now there's really not all
that much prague can do here he does
have one pawn but there is very little
you can do with this one extra pawn
against the full knight so g3 we have g6
and queen to f for now uh queen to b2
putting more pressure on the f2 pawn
rook to f1 and now just rook the c8 and
it was in this position on mu 42 that
pragernanda resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the rook is now coming to see uh sorry
the c6 and then to f6 this is covered by
the knight and it will be impossible to
keep an eye on this uh
f2 pawn even if you add the king to the
the defense of the pawn after rook to f6
uh the queen will no longer be able to
defend and everything will just uh uh
drop so there's no saving this probably
of course sees this he resigns and ding
takes game one of their match so we'll
see what happens if prague bounces back
or will uh will ding maybe take the
victory without even having to play the
four games there's still quite a lot of
chess to enjoy and i do hope that we we
get to enjoy it uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed the big
congratulations to ding on this
beautiful victory even though uh prague
did get get some chances he didn't he
just didn't see them uh i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to salvatore
canoe uh rob uh i and i would like to
thank uh robert key for mark manner
nagarjuna
and
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
until it ends uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day